big government isn't backing down from
snooping on your bank account after
causing a firestorm of controversy with
a new proposal that would require banks
to inform the government about accounts
making transactions you're ready over
600 big money
treasury secretary janet yellen is
trying to convince americans that that
really isn't spying
does this mean that the government is
trying to peek into our pocketbooks if
you want to look at 600 transactions
absolutely not the proposal involves no
reporting of individual transactions we
have a tax gap that over the next decade
is estimated at seven trillion dollars
namely a shortfall in the amount that
irs is collecting
due to
a failure
of individuals to report the income that
they've earned
but don't worry nancy pelosi says the
controversial provision will remain in
the democrats reconciliation bill
despite a lot of public concerns
remember judge when they told us you
know the fbi's not going to be spying
and listening to people then the next
thing you know they abuse every law spy
and then leak who was it who sat before
congress and said no the nsa doesn't spy
on us and then his eyes looked left he
said not woody
james clapper not wittingly right i hate
it when people lie to me i actually
wrote a book called don't lie to me okay
here is the problem with what's her name
janet yellen she says it involves no
reporting of individual transactions we
are not spying but there's a shortfall a
tax gap a failure of some to report
income there's a lot of tax fraud so
we're going to require banks to report
every customer transaction over 600. she
is lying to you they are spying on you
600 or more now the bank is now an agent
of the irs and that's the point geraldo
you can't have the banks deputized by
the feds to snoop on american citizens
well we have that now let's remember
that no but
my point is the banks have been
empowered and required
to report transactions of ten thousand
dollars and more why because of dope
dealers you know all the cash business
so
you get your cash a stack of cash you
write a check you're laundering the
money the banks can see that's a lot
different
you know you know many people don't let
their spouse look at their checkbook
that's right and they have the uh the
irs and the bank not me my wife controls
all their finances she does yeah oh
that's not a good idea herreal though
especially with your finances
at my age right dana yellen is not
she doesn't have great pr right now they
put her out there they tried to make
this thing look okay and i don't think
she did a very good job the other thing
is that they are going i i believe that
they will drop this provision
before they ever actually pass it so
they're taking on all of this water and
negative press for a reason that is for
no reason really in the end and that
makes her however you know who this is
really affecting young people who use
ben mo yeah right right
like babysitters and things like that
they're good and all of a sudden like
wait
you're gonna oh oh because it's income
if we were really serious about dealing
with the issue of what janet yellen is
saying is that people underpay we would
actually do a flat income tax or a
national retail sales tax and end
and the income tax all together so that
people i think that would be a much more
fair thing to do it's just that it's
hard for people to get that in their
heads and if anything's hard you don't
do it in washington yeah the venmo thing
i didn't even think about that greg
there's a lot of things you don't think
about jessica i know you can spend all
day yeah yeah i think that should be a
special stuff jesse didn't think about
fascination
when you think about the fact that the
the soho gallery got a half a million
dollars in ppp yeah yeah to show hunters
paintings right you can flee that's
taxpayer money that went to that
that gallery but it's the taxpayers that
are getting targeted and hunter is not
that should make your blood boil i love
the fact that she didn't deny it she
said it's not happening but then she
goes well the reason we're tracking
smoke it gives you the reason um it's a
shortfall and i go well so the reason
that you're that's not a denial you
don't yeah i am robbing you because i'm
broke no you're supposed to say i'm not
robbing you but she didn't so she so she
she admits it's a power a power grab
and all of these people tyra said this a
couple of nights ago on the show it is
about the waitresses the bartenders the
small businesses
that money's not going to go into the
bank babysitters you're going to have to
start you're going to have it's going to
go right back into the mattress right 1
800 mattress the new bank that's right a
coffee can buried in the backyard that's
what i do dana with money and other
things
joins the basement it's never been a
better time to buy gold yeah all right
cb william
i want to front one of those coming up
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else